annonce de nouvelles sanctions
aujourd'hui de l'union européenne contre
la biélorussie suite à la sphère du
déroutement d'un vol ryanair en mai
dernier des mesures punitives prises en
coordination avec les états unis
washington qui prévoit également de
sanctionner à nouveau la russie dans le
cadre de l' affaire présumée
du présumé empoisonnement de l'opposant
alexeï navalni mais malgré cela la
reprise de contact entre le kremlin et
la maison blanche se confirme
illustration avec le retour à washington
de l'ambassadeur russe
et ce cinq jours après la rencontre à
genève entre les présidents russe et
américain vladimir poutine joe barton la
correspondance à moscou d'anthony
claireaux sitôt la parenthèse de genève
refermez les ambassadeurs revenus à leur
poste
on semble assister un retour aux
affaires courantes entre moscou et
washington conseillé de joe biden à la
sécurité nationale jack sullivan a en
effet fait savoir que de nouvelles
sanctions étaient en préparation dans le
cadre de la sphère navx a mis des
sanctions qui pourrait bien concerner
une nouvelle fois le projet de gazoduc
north stream 2 entre l'allemagne et la
russie
vous propose d'écouter la réaction du
porte-parole du kremlin les propos du
président concernant l'attitude
constructive lors du sommet ne signifie
pas que nous nous écartions d'une
évaluation réaliste de nos relations
bilatérales avec les états unis dans ses
relations
l'essentiel et le pragmatisme et le
réalisme les deux concepts signifie qu
les résultats constructifs positifs du
sommet n'entraîne pas du tout l'abandon
par les etats-unis de l'essence même de
leur politique de dissuasion envers la
russie attendent store une image de
notre cave à et politique
nous sommes conscients du fait que
c'était ainsi et que cela continuera
christophe a également souligné qu'il
pouvait y avoir de grandes différences
entre ce qui se dit entre les chefs
d'état et ce qui se passe effectivement
sur le terrain ces dernières années dans
nos relations bilatérales notamment avec
l'administration précédente
et même avant nous avons un entreprise
fait face à des situations où une
entente à laquelle on n'a pas revenue au
plus haut niveau était par la suite
condamné à une inaction totale de
stephen bailey
et a priori une désactivation de la part
de comme vous voulez on peut dire au
niveau opérationnel ou par l'état
profond peu importe que pascal a rappelé
olivier lecat voiture c'est donc un
retour à la réalité qui semble se
dessiner dans les relations entre les
états unis et la russie
à la différence près que cette fois ci
moscou espère que le dialogue pourra
continuer